a bunch of questions for you
um you've now shot three seasons of
Vikings Valhalla which season do you
think ended up being the more
challenging of the seasons and I'm just
wondering if it's season one because
that's where you're like starting
everything and figuring out your
characters and all that
I think for me season two was the most
challenging one I I felt so connected to
Freitas from the moment I was first
introduced to her in the self tape stage
and filming season one was such an
instinctual journey I mean I had the
best cast members my brother and my
lover to lean on and we just worked so
well together and season two was a bit
of a challenge we're pulled apart from
each other you guys
continue your Bromance and I'm diving
into a whole new world as a mother so
it's a very vulnerable experience and it
was definitely the some of the scenes we
shot were absolutely the most
challenging I've ever done in my career
yeah I would um I'd hesitate to say one
was they all had their different
challenges I think yes season one The
Challenge is kicking things off and
um really pitching where that you want
that character to be and then in the the
seasons that follow it's it's more it's
more in your body already it feels more
natural
um and we had covered contentment in the
first season which put this whole
strange parameter on on how you go about
filmmaking
um and I think this the challenges for
season two Harold had to like
do some big fight scenes and and torture
scenes so so physically there was a
challenge in in the second season that
that surmounted the one that I'd faced
in in the first season yeah and just
wait till season three and and and for
myself like likewise with Frida first
season felt very instinctual felt like
we were hitting the stride very nicely
uh the second season for me was
definitely the most challenging on an
emotional level uh you know we're seeing
the falling apart of a man and you know
when you're playing a role you can't
help but open yourself to the aspects
where your life is similar to theirs or
you're searching for that inspiration
around you so if you're searching for
you know sorrow grief anger you're gonna
find it in your own life like because
you're living in that world for so long
and so I I found it mentally and
emotionally probably that the hardest
part of the filming of the last of the
whole three seasons and the second
season it was something Jeb said early
on he's he's throwing these characters
out of our comfort zones all of them
were banished we're Exiles and so if we
did get comfortable and thought we knew
where we were and by the end of season
one we got thrown out into a whole
different set of circumstances and and
it was a big refresh a big reset Harold
gonna pray to say goodbye early on and
and Leif and Harold find themselves in
foreign lands last night we spoke a lot
about season two I got a whole bunch of
information thing I didn't ask you guys
at all was about season three so I'm
just gonna say effort and throw it out
uh obviously you three survive into
season three I'm assuming so what can
you say about it as compared to the
first two seasons without sort of giving
it away you know what I mean because we
haven't gotten to the end of two yet
there's Netflix people in the room all
right so how legit yeah
I don't mess around I go right for the
jugular why not no it's good it's both
of you do that I mean season three is
absolutely incredible and I can't wait
to talk to you about it when we get the
chance but now we're in season two and
that's also incredibly exciting so let's
stay here yeah sure no totally live
quotes from last night that I'm going to
use you know but that was a very good
maneuver I appreciate that yeah I think
for life you know in season two we're
kind of you know I'm sure you may have
felt in your life when you became doing
the job you're doing you were like oh
this is exactly what I'm meant to be
doing and uh the the kind of steps to
that realization is what season two is
and as we come to season three he
realized oh this is exactly what I'm
meant to be doing
I'd I'd add to that as well because I
think yeah here we go
season two is like the beginning the the
early stage of the transformation of
Harold sigurdson into Harold hardrada is
this is the man who the the
Legends are about and yeah season two is
the early stage of that season three is
going to be a continuation of this this
transformation of a prince into a king
thank you for answering the question
some of you I'm confusing I'm teasing
when you were reading when you're
reading the scripts and you see what are
you more excited to see a meaty dialogue
scene or a scene where you get to
absolutely kick ass
midi dialogue for me yeah midi dialogue
to be able to uh like this show has such
pace and an amazing action but to have
that time that moment of Stillness where
we get to express what's actually
internally going on with our characters
and often it's you know with one one
another although we we part ways with uh
Freitas myself and Harold or Leif and
Harold uh Loaf and Harold certainly
shows something uh show a part of
themselves to each other that they don't
show anyone else and that's really those
moments they're the North Stars for one
another that yeah we have nice scenes
where when things are down and when when
Harold or lake needs a pick me up we
both sort of provide it at different
times yeah yeah
I love for freighters she doesn't really
I mean saying good bye to
us meaningful people in her life she
gave season two kind of
by herself it's a kind of an internal
season and for me I love being able to
have these quiet kind of moments of
solitude whether it be if it is praying
or Fred is rediscovering you pay you
know new things in her faith or
discovering the temple in the forest and
just those little delightful kind of
quiet moments I think were my were my
favorite season like that but you it's
hard to tell on the page when you read
an action sequence on a page it never
does Justice to actually what it is when
you see it on in a stunt shed so that
moment of walking in and seeing what
those stunt guys have cooked up for you
and what you're gonna have to perform
early on it's quite daunting yeah oh wow
how am I gonna how am I gonna do this
but they they're an amazing team a shout
out to them because they they make sure
that we do so my last question for the
three of you making a show like this is
a huge team effort uh the crew the cast
the camera everybody has to come
together for each of you who's an unsung
hero someone that you just want to give
a shout out to that without their
participation the show does not happen
yeah I think from
from Audrey who were
so
a three seasons in very complex costumes
she works to dress me and she is
just fantastic drag all of my incredibly
heavy armor up and down mountains
helping me go to the restroom when I
can't unzip my pants because the
Wardrobe is too heavy we get to know
each other incredibly well and she is
the best shout out to Audrey Marcia
would be the because we get to work
really early 4 30 but there's a whole
bunch of people who are there way
earlier than us
um and but yeah in those early morning
hours you're there with your your makeup
team and your hair team so Tom and Kate
and Peter thank you guys yes I had the
best time they're the first people you
see in the last people you see and and
that sets you up for the day so big
laugh Tom Joey Virginia Adriana Kenny
Shane Russell good go on how long you
got yeah well listen I just want to say
congrats uh I really do hope the show
keeps on uh running and thank you so
much for your time thank you so much